hi there good morning and welcome to
Warsaw here in poland's home of said a
project red the team behind the witcher
a gaming franchise based around the
short stories novels of mr. Angiers a
pesky and now one of the most
anticipated games of 2015
if you like video games you've heard of
The Witcher but it's a series that's
intimidated a lot of the gaming audience
since it first appeared in 2007 the game
is often associated with complex RPG
mechanics deep lore and hardcore combat
so despite its notoriety there's
probably a good chance you've not played
a Witcher game before well I can tell
you now that's all about to change
with Wild Hunt so why am I here well
games part was given the opportunity to
gain unprecedented access to a
near-complete version of the game so we
booked the flights packed up the cameras
and then spent the past couple of days
playing the game and talking to the
development team behind this open-world
Witcher and this week we're going to
share everything we learned with you
so using exclusive new gameplay of this
impressive open-world RPG candid
interviews from the Lee producers on the
project and our own impressions after a
combined 12 hours playing Wild Hunt this
week we're going to tell you everything
we've learned the scale of its world the
types of quests you'll undertake it's
dynamic story how it plays on PC how it
looks on consoles and how Wild Hunt is
said to be one of the biggest hits of
2015
Goku but before we travel to the vast
and varied world of The Witcher 3 we
must first go to an equally bizarre
place this story starts in 80's Warsaw
in a poland shrouded in the cloud of
Soviet Communism
[Music]
the year is 1988 gamers in the United
States are enjoying the fruits of the
Nintendo Entertainment System it's the
year Super Mario Bros 2 and Zelda 2d
Adventures of link reached North
American shelves and in Japan the Mega
Drive or Genesis is being launched
however to the east of Germany things
are a lot different the Republic of
Poland had been decimated during World
War two and in the years following
Poland limped on swallowed up by the
Union of Soviet Socialist Republics it
was operated for decades by a communist
party in distance Co the Palace of
Culture a Soviet gift to the poles stood
like a combine citadel over Warsaw
citizens this was a state where trade
was practically non-existent every
aspect of life was run by a centralized
government and so while very real walls
blocked some from the outer world the
lack of trade with the outside world
created a cultural wall that covered an
area the size of a continent tear down
the wall but this didn't mean that
people didn't find a way to get a hold
of Western media music films and even
games were brought across the border
from neighboring countries they were
copied traded replicated and spread
across cities and regions people would
go to computer exchanges and swap copies
of games freely and it wasn't even
technically illegal but it's not as if
piracy was just accepted here in Poland
it was actually completely illegal
there's no such thing as copyright law
in communist States so what all the kids
in Europe were illegally copying their
Commodore 64 games by hitting play and
record on tape decks here in Poland
radio stations were literally
broadcasting them over the airwaves so
you could just sit at home tune in to
your favorite radio station and record
c64 games right there and then games
were so free here in Poland that they
were literally flying through the air
when the Berlin Wall came down in 1989
communism fell to its knees and
capitalism flooded into Poland from
across its Western German border more
media than ever before sold by a brand
new generation of entrepreneurs open-air
markets became the place to buy these
Goods and his trade increased the
importing scene grew and grew and as
founder Marsh in divinsky reminisces
this is where said a project was born so
the co-founder me helped me hope to
change key back in high school and our
passion was to play games so we're
skipping school playing games so we were
you know on the local forums on the
international forums and at a certain
point through this context I realized
that there's a new cool thing called
cd-roms right now I think you can make
the sophisticated guess of our company
name CD Projekt we are probably the
first people in Poland to import games
and CD ROMs
initially we didn't really not for
business but we wanted to play these
games after a while we thought hey maybe
there is some business we could do so ah
let's try i was importing 1 or 2 units
per title and miho was selling them on
the local computer exchange there was a
cry for that so you know before people
were isolated it's something wow you can
get your hands on exciting stuff the
biggest change was from 94 and onwards
initially I think in 94 1 when the
software started selling a lot of people
a lot of consumers were like hey how
should I buy something original and I
can have it for free we were educating
people that buying games makes sense and
has value initially you have to really
serve them this value in a very physical
like touchable far I still it is
actually think it's important because if
you look at the boxes of our region
titles there's a lot of stuffing so yeah
especially in Eastern Europe especially
in Poland people just didn't know why on
earth they should buy software it's free
you get it from the friend so why are we
talking about the Polish piracy scene
well because the seeds of this consumer
centric culture of game sales is bearing
fruits today a culture we're serving the
consumer value was an important aspect
of trade and this value centric
mentality is no more apparent
and when you look at her CD Projekt is
going to handle DLC for Wild Hunt tell
me about the DLC plan this what's the
interesting sort of tactic it's free
it's just like this yeah I mean what we
really think the word DLC it's to
valuate it there are some duties which
are like good old expansions and then
I'll probably prefer to call them
expansion yeah if it's a DLC if it's
hairstyle or weapon or more horse armor
maybe this should be this should be for
free really and this is our way of
saying thank you to the gamers or buying
our game also we want to encourage them
show them hey guys we have something in
store for you really care when you buy
our game consider buying it that's it
that's always their choice you know it
seems like you're doing the same thing
you did with the with the boxes before
like sticking in all this free stuff
of course because honestly speaking what
does it cost us to make set of hours oh
I don't know
several hours maybe one to three people
hey considering the scale of the game
I'm considering that investment people
will be taking in the game spending two
hours hey let's make it more fun time
for them so I think it's kind of obvious
I would like to get such stuff for free
that's what we're doing here [ __ ] CD
Projekt understand sales they published
in distributed games to the Polish
market in some form or another for over
20 years what type of game do you make
when your company was founded on
distributing Western media around
post-socialist Poland while CD Projekt
decided to flip the script buying the
games rights to one of their nations
literature treasures and creating a game
that they could share with people around
the world our dream was always to make
our own game but we had the sport with
all this history with seven books right
now it's eight we only have creative
freedom so we bought out the part of the
world and we had full creative freedom I
think the fact that we had this freedom
created sort of a paranoia because we
thought okay we have this Eastern
European fans who
really know every single bidding piece
in the game the first two games in this
series were critical darlings are
incredibly popular with the pc
role-playing crowd because of their
challenging combat system and rich
fiction but for all they did well which
are one an assassins of kings were both
pretty terrible at introducing newcomers
to their complex mechanics and rich lore
but from my time playing Wild Hunt
thankfully this is something CD Projekt
I've spent some time trying to fix after
a brief story segment we won't get into
for free of spoilers you begin the game
in a relatively small open-world area
this miniature version of the game's
main open-world acts as a playground for
the first few hours of the game here
you'll take on a few story missions
explore solve side quests and get used
to the game's mechanics so what are
these mechanics well for the uninitiated
you play as Geralt of Rivia a legendary
Witcher witcher's are a band of highly
trained monster hunters who are mutated
at a young age to be experts in their
field as such Geralt carries two swords
silver for killing beasts and steel for
human brains he is gifted in magic and
can cast a range of spells or signs to
both defend and attack and as an
alchemist he can collect different
ingredients around the world and concoct
potions he can't drink too many of these
though as each potion increases gerelds
chance of toxicity this is a good
example of an area in which Wild Hunt is
bending a knee for both newcomers and
its new open-world gameplay while
previous games required you to prepare
for combat by meditating and taking
potions beforehand in Witcher 3 you'll
be able to prepare potions during
meditation and consume them any time
during combat and while previous games
required you to collect specific
ingredients to refill these potions in
Wild Hunt
every time you meditate the potions
you've crafted will refill themselves
using whatever alcohol reserves you have
unlike most third-person action games
combat in The Witcher 3 isn't just a
series of hacks and slashes it's far
more deliberate and engaging and it
plays much like The Witcher 2 sword
strikes must be timed monster movements
must be studied and certain combinations
of potions signs and weapons make for
the best attack human enemies can lose
stamina just as quickly as Geralt can
and when they do it allows you to
unleash devastating
blows this makes our play far more
engaging sword fighting on horseback
allows you to slow down time for brutal
attacks and while this footage makes
chopping up mobs look easy we played
around with the game's difficulty
settings and on anything other than easy
Wild Hunt combat can be as punishing as
games like Dark Souls however if you
don't want to get your sword dirty
conversations are an equally important
aspect of completing quests in the
prologue area there are plenty of people
to talk to barmaids dwarfs with side
quests sometimes you can talk yourself
out of a situation or cast a sign but
it's not always possible sometimes the
game pushes you into a corner and you
are forced to fight out of it this is
the game with a lot going on and it
feels far more polished than the
previous games in the series in this
respect but it's the way in which these
systems work together fluidly that makes
it incredibly fun to spend time in this
world walking into villages chatting to
the locals and picking your quests using
your Witcher skills to track down
monsters and solve local mysteries
wandering into other towns across hills
and even into buildings seamlessly
without loading screens in my first few
hours of the game I slayed some random
bear got an X or fight in a pub and
wandered into random cave full of nasty
creatures it's that type of game keep in
mind though this already prologue area
is designed to instill this sort of
wonder so it's too early to tell if this
variety will keep you hooked a few
dozens of hours in well dive into the
type of quests and missions in another
video but this prologue area does
achieve something that the previous
games in this series never did it gives
you the tools and time to get to grips
with some relatively complex systems CD
Projekt are clearly trying to reach for
a larger audience with this witcher you
only have to look at how the logo has
changed to figure that one out this is
intentional that this sort of when you I
remember looking at the branding for
Witcher 3 when I first came out with the
trailers and there's a big three and now
it looks like Wild Hunt the three is
become like a scratch in the middle this
is kind of like a I get it crown of the
Wild Hunt like that at the certain point
we realized that we might be isolating a
lot of gamers who'll come to the store
and will say I haven't played The
Witcher The Witcher are wild under
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt are its fully
playable on its own you don't need
you know anything
in many ways this is the coming-of-age
of The Witcher it's the first time
several of the dreams of its creators
have been even possible the first time
it's been set in an open world on the
first time it's coming out on both
consoles and PC simultaneously so is it
any good well tomorrow here on GameSpot
in part 2 we unveil the world of The
Witcher 3 its vast open landscapes that
beasts that inhabit it and of course how
an open world fundamentally changes this
fantasy will take Ceres see you then
[Music]
you
[Music]